welcome to CBS mornings we're going to
begin with a major development in the
fight against covid Pfizer has won an
emergency use authorization from the FDA
for its vaccine booster shot this
applies only to older Americans at the
moment and those at high risk so far big
picture about 64 percent of eligible
Americans are fully vaccinated and our
wishing is at the White House for us
following all of this Ouija before
people run out to their local pharmacy
there is one more step I understand it
before these boosters can be made
available good morning Good morning Tony
and good morning to everybody you are
right even though the FDA has approved
the Pfizer booster for some people a
panel of advisors to the CDC has to vote
on who is eligible to get them before
the government makes them available
that's expected to happen today and then
the CDC director has to formally adopt
the recommendations but the White House
expects shots to start going into Arms
by the end of the week
the FDA has authorized a Pfizer booster
shot for people who are 65 years and
older as well as adults 18 through 64
years old who are at high risk for
severe covid-19 or serious complications
from frequent exposure to the virus like
health care workers the White House had
hoped that the general population could
start getting them this week and even
announced a rollout plan in August we'll
be ready to start these booster this
booster program during the week of
September 20. on the CBS News podcast
the takeout Dr Anthony fauci discussed
studies that show the vaccine's
effectiveness wanes over time will it
continue to come down which it is doing
it is more so in Israel because Israel
is ahead of us by about a month a month
and a half and they're seeing it come
down significantly Dr fauci also said
the FDA is still waiting for more data
from moderna and Johnson and Johnson
before authorizing their boosters which
is expected to happen in the next few
weeks researchers are also looking at
whether mix and match vaccines are a
safe and effective way to boost
protection mix and match means if I get
moderna as my primary and second shot
can I get a J and J or a Pfizer for my
my Boost we don't project major that
there is going to be any difference or
any signal of concern to do that
Dr fauci also said that those who may
have already gotten their third dose
without this official guide and should
probably be okay but they prefer that
you wait to hear from officials now
there is one bright spot to report this
morning one model estimates that the U.S
is already through the worst of the
Delta variant and that both cases and
deaths will start to steadily decline
into the spring if more kids get
vaccinated and if a new variant doesn't
take off so Gail here is hoping
I know we need hope these days thank you
very much weja